Just stepping through this diagram,
okay?
We start off with some
underlying distribution,
pardon my inability to trace, okay?
But, of course, we don't actually
have a real distribution.
What we have is a set of particles,
okay?
Those particles are not
uniformly weighted, remember?
The sum of all the weights is one, some
particles have more weight than others.
That is, they,
that particle has a higher probability.
All right?
So here's what we do.
The first thing we do is we draw
a set of samples from this set, okay?
Now, you'll notice here, in this nice
picture, one of my big particles happen
to gets, to get sampled three times,
the medium particles got sampled twice.
And the this one got sampled once.
And by the way,
notice, how many times that these
itty-bitty particles get sampled?
Not at all.
That's okay, because you're doing a
random sample because it corresponds to
the density, and that random sampling
sometimes gets all the particles,
sometimes only gets the ones
with significant weights.
So, we do the sampling.
Now, the next thing you'll see is that
each one of these particles has been
shifted, but you'll notice that
the shifts are not always the same.
So, why do you think that is?
Do you know why that is?
>> There's a deterministic part,
nothing says that my deterministic
part has to be the same for all my
guesses of the previous state, okay?
Let's suppose what I do is I take a step
proportional to the number of lines
that are on the floor, right?
So I'm going to step three lines.
But if the lines are closer
here than they were over here.
Relax, Megan.
Then going three step, three lines over
here would actually mean I'd moved
a smaller amount than
if I was over here.
If I had gone three lines,
I would have gone a further amount.
All this means is that
the deterministic part
doesn't have to be the same everywhere.
It's just deterministic.
Then, we add in essentially what could
be thought of as the diffusion part or
the uncertainty part.
Remember when we were
generating the new sample,
we did the deterministic part,
plus the probabilistic part.
And that's what's here, right?
So, after we take a sample and
we move it, we add some noise.
And we do that every time
we have drawn a sample.
So since we did three
samples from this particle,
it ended up at three different places.
Likewise for all the others.
Then what we do is we
take our measurement, and
we've got p of z given x.
That's what this value is.
And we just multiply these weights,
which are all 1 to start with,
by that value, okay?
Oh, here it is.
p of z given X.
We just multiply it, and we end up
with this new set of particles, okay?
So if I erase my, my figures there you
take a look, that's a beautiful figure.
It's all of particle filtering.
Just sleep with it under your pillow and
you'll be in, in great shape.